well uh a little news coming out of
jacksonville now
sending out some text messages to pick
up some more details that
media says the jaguars have cut running
back
leonard fournette cut gone out
i saw it characterized by someone who's
waved no he's got four years in
right he's in his option year he becomes
a free agent he doesn't have to pass
through waivers
he can sign with anyone he wants um
the thing though is he's got that
guaranteed contract for this year that
guaranteed contract still may be the
subject
of an arbitration because remember it's
been a couple of years now the jaguars
tried to invalidate the guaranteed money
remaining in his contract because of the
suspension against buffalo when he ran
across the field
and and got into a fight and got
suspended for that game and i think some
other things they threw onto that fire
to try to avoid owing him his money
fully guaranteed
without offsets either so it's not going
to matter if if someone else pays him
the jaguars always do their first round
draft pick
full guarantee top ten and they're in
the top ten it seems like every year
with no offset language so this is all
free money if fournette wins
but you know chris when they were trying
to trade him yeah earlier this year
one of the things that was said to me
and i think it makes a ton of sense
and it helps explain this he doesn't fit
that offense
the jay gruden offense is not a fit for
leonard fournette and i think they've
realized after a month of training camp
it doesn't make sense
to try to cram a square peg into a round
hole i mean i'm still surprised
yes i mean he is not that style of
runner
maybe for the the jay gruden offense
i get that but man just to release him
and let him go
a guy that's as talented as leonard
fournette i am surprised i just i wonder
what happened here i mean this is a guy
that i just i somebody's gonna gobble
him up
i mean he's gonna go to waivers now
right mike is that is that oh yeah don't
wait freeze total i'm totally
gonna go anywhere he wants oh my gosh
whoa all right just
i mean just because i'm i'm in fanboy
mode right now i'm already thinking
pittsburgh steelers are going for
leonard fournette
that's who we said yeah that's who we
said should trade for him yeah i know
how you're getting them for free now
you're gonna get them for free
yeah look at what he did in pittsburgh
right we need to dust off our draft
didn't we do a draft of who should who
should trade for
leonard and that that was the pre-draft
though so that may have changed some
things
but they only got the anthony mcfarlane
kid out of uh
you know maryland dealers definitely so
definitely right any other teams that
jump into your brain here as you sit
here and look at this right away i'm
just trying to
quickly go through it um seattle
seahawks they got some
you know injury issues up there would
they want to mess with a guy like that
because of you know of course
uh uh rashad penny coming back from
injury and chris carson
man the philadelphia eagles we know they
got a running back issue right now too
they might be involved in this
conversation too is this
the chicago bears we know david
montgomery just went down right a little
bit i don't know
i don't think it's anything serious with
the groin injury
so yeah there's going to be some suitors
for leonard fournette he's just too big
too physical too raw of a specimen
to sit out there for long there's been a
lot of buzz about chris thompson coming
out of jaguars camp now look he's more
of a change of pace guy
five eight one ninety five but uh you
look at this depth chart
they may have to trade for somebody
maybe they trade for james connor
after the still sign leonard fournette
and and this tells me
that they made one last ditch effort to
trade leonard fournette you just don't
cut him like that you at least make a
couple of phone calls
uh to see if there's any interest
whatsoever in leonard fournette but they
decided to move on we have to move on
but we'll talk about this later in the
program and if not
we'll pick it up in pftot who takes over
for the jaguars in the backfield
where does leonard fernett land who are
the teams that should pursue leonard for
that maybe we'll put out a question on
twitter and see what
folks have to say about that for now
though we're going to stay in the state
of florida we're going to take a break
state of the franchise
number six on the pft preseason power
rankings a team that hasn't been in the
playoffs in a very long time
and he poised to crash the party this
year with hashtag tommy at quarterback
we'll talk
buccaneers when pft live continues right
after this
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports